how's he doing guys welcome through the
Brooklyn podcast my name is PewDiePie hi
guys I'm cinnamon tools can power your
voices sound so different couldn't even
tell it wasn't me I don't think we
thought that through no anyway welcome
today we brought our lady friends for
the show because we always I at least
always complain about playing about your
lady friends I don't know just about
their use of candles so we're gonna do
to start up this week's broken podcast
we asked you guys to select five items
as a challenge and we're gonna guess
what they are for their beauty challenge
right know each other depending on how
ugly are they're they're a challenge uh
and whoever gets the most right is the
best boyfriend yeah the morph element
feminine boyfriend which is the best ken
is so feminine so look at me
[Music]
that maybe it makes sense today
subscribe it okay it's it looks like
those kind of evil perfumes that you
squish on the back and it comes out like
you see in movies and I know it
available some merry okay well you can
guess after me then can do you know what
I mean
no evil perfumes evil evil perfect Oh
like a Cruella and yeah it's a big
Jewish thing in the back yeah
yes oh my god yeah well what else would
it be oh my god stuff is coming out oh
it's powder mm-hmm how der is coming out
it's glitter spray yeah too bad you took
you two tries to get it you lose okay
fine fine yeah not too manly for this
challenge this should be evil perfume it
be way cooler I think hey man give me
something that what's that all right
this looks like a doughnut it's like a
peach colored doughnut yeah it's got a
hole in the middle and it's squishy is
like a sponge about oh it's kind of
rough on top so maybe it's for
exfoliating
ignaty its exfoliating your skin you
know or maybe you sit on it because it's
a no it fits in my hand easily hits it's
not very bad uh so yeah I'm gonna go
with the exfoliating thingy for your
face no that means this Candy's a virgin
it's a frickin is a doughnut yes what is
it it's a hair bow know what that is I
figure like dig my thumb in there I mean
it's freaking so nice it's like it it's
not even like soft or pretty it looks
like a peach looking doughnut it doesn't
look like something to stick in your
hair
is it a weird texture on it yeah yeah
yeah it feels like Ted stick I stick my
thumb in its thumb in it and it's like a
butthole yeah right it does feel like it
can I get a really dry old bottle zero
fine Dan you both suck oh my god what is
this banana banana
it is literally a tiny banana I squeeze
it and it feels soft in my hand I have
this urge to touch it and I open it and
it looks like a mustard and bottle thing
so if I put this in my mouth will I get
my suit
no how will I know what add a face if I
don't taste it what it smells like
banana - looks like banana smells like
banana it's gonna be a banana it's gonna
be man in it it tastes like banana -
really yeah I I don't
II do something I don't know it's for
your nostrils no come on one guess no I
don't know oh my god so annoying oh oh
it's a moisturizer well well it's a
moisturizer for something else not what
you expect your bottle it's a hand cream
[Music]
what do I have for you what's this
alright this is a little a little bitty
toothpaste looking tube that has tape
around it so I can't tell what it is
it says model Co at the top
it's purple silver top and we open the
top and see what comes out
Mary's backing up like I'm meant to just
explosion any more descriptions there
I'm a some black stuff came out it looks
like I don't know what that is so yeah
it's like a little bitty toothpaste tube
it's some kind of makeup I guess but I
don't know what because it's just a
frickin tube so what do you reckon you
would do with something like that it
smells good ain't no hints it's kind of
dark purple maybe I'd put it around my
eyes
why would you have to get that to get
that shadowy bedroom look you know that
sounds cool I don't know that's what I
say it is am I wrong
you are wrong of course it's not like
you were right out of the way what is it
it's a cheek and lip tint so now your
fingers are gonna be staged now cuz you
just yeah it's a good thing you didn't
it's a stain same yes you can stain your
lips or your chin cheeks pink okay I
lose again you feel like you're sorry
oh I promise okay next one next one I
know what this is you do so this looks
like a like a mascara I'm gonna open it
to see I feel like it evil love got him
I got Jamie it looks identical to
mascara but it's white instead of black
hmm can you keep it's a moisturizer damn
it why did you tape over it
[Music]
why would white what out you
I don't know maybe you said this would
be easy I'm guessing that the brow gel
no no a primer for the lashes I was just
about to say that
of course primer primer for the lashes
it's like a um it's a tube black on the
bottom and it's got black top but then
it's kind of see-through in the middle
like I don't know what that would be
looks like it reminds me a ninja turtles
the news
let's take off the top gotta take off
the top it's got like a little squirt on
the top of it or actually okay and clear
stuff comes out yeah so this stuff is
oily and you put it on your lips I think
you should try it
mmm mmm smell very good
yeah it's must I make it does mess with
my grandma but it's super oily so I
guess is it raise it like your Beulah is
that is that your makeup concealer stuff
what I never that stuff you had that you
like this let's make you make it last
longer no good guess that me now this is
a great guess Amiga three faith theorem
so I put it on in the evenings after I
turn but before I moisturize what you
got I can order into this stuff yeah I
hope my nightly routine it's why it
takes me like half an hour in the
bathroom before I go sleep like it's not
like me and Ken could pull up five items
and be like yeah what is this this is my
toothbrush you've got a yo-yo beard
cersei oh yeah anyway all right
I still got nothing right suck my turn
okay
and okay this is very kawaii it's a look
could be a tiny toothpaste I'm gonna say
no that it's not I'm gonna say this is a
skin product oh my gosh she just goes to
everything squeeze on it and her police
stuff is coming out very watery forget
I don't do creams on my hand woman sorry
okay no no way man why did you put it
out okay look it looks like paint it
looks like you're painting your hand
right oh my god it's disgusting it's
like and as I like what is this demon
cream with a solid color or is it like a
little bit see-through
it's it's solid a solid lilac cream I've
got no idea it does blend in yes it does
blend in which is really creepy like
where does it lie let go oh okay it's
that cream yep or your arm
face face it's a face cream that soft in
your face it's like a you're like
interrogating her down it's a hand no
face cream and it's at one step base yes
huh a face basic I know what it is yeah
what do you put face face
I don't know an oceanic oh my god I hate
life okay just get it get the last one
done yes turn alright so what is my face
this is a little pink piece it looks
like it's a piece of paper but it's
shaped like it's connected to in so it
makes like a like a little cup shape but
it feels rough like sandpaper ish keep
your hand in it maybe yeah yeah all the
way there by the way by the way it was
anyway the bigger way on the bigger part
of your head oh yeah you can either hand
you can wait you could totally sandpaper
something with this is it is it the
thing for your legs sandpaper is it the
thing for your legs the same paper your
hairs yes my leg says the leg sandpaper
of course yeah it's an alternative to
shaving does it take the stubble down is
that what it does yeah it um it like
turns the hairs into dust this can you
get one point there because I don't
think he deserves it yeah he totally did
how do you think I don't deserve that
what are you talking about I got that
right I didn't ask 21 questions in
borrowed this from my sister when I was
a kid no what could that be it looks
like a sister and it looks like you're
gonna cut off your eyelashes with it
okay oh yeah you know that is an eyelash
is full of malaya nicer illuminizer you
get it wrong by Iser
whatever they [ __ ] that's what they
should call it from now on one point
yes oh so we got the last our last one
which says eclipse pellet on it from
Coastal Scents wait one second aim if I
if I guess it first I I win everything
how about that I can open it up and
there's a bunch of colors inside you
should say what all the colors are
there's white yellow kind of a teal
green pink that a bunch of different
shades of brown it's a Roush what that's
a ruse it's a ruse it's all the ruse I
really don't know what a rouges I don't
know I'd say it's like a shock to me
like Chiara she can make up to make like
you're sure it's the thing you put on
the cheeks blush what does it make it
snow why would you have green blush
Felix
if you're a troll I don't know uh I
guessed it was again take it back I'm a
cheater like it's a concealer and color
corrector so you use the green when
you've got like red skin and pimples
because it's the opposite end of the
color spectrum that cancels it out and
you use the yellow when you've got like
dark under-eye circles and then all the
Browns are just to conceal like all
different skin tones okay we're equally
feminine I guess so we've got one point
feminine one femininity Finding Nemo mud
Sam you are perfect in there every
single way but you have a lot of flaws
you are so perfect and I love you so
much but there's so much wrong with you
that I don't even I'm just kidding we
are giving you there's a chance to tell
us what they don't like about us because
that's humorous no way that's full of
love so Mary go ahead and tell me tell
me something you like something I don't
like about you yeah well no you can't go
Oh something that can just has never
ever learned how to do despite my
consistent efforts is letting his dishes
in the dishwasher I mean usually it's
got clean dishes in any way throw em on
I mean you see him and you put yours
there too so I want to hear it
well well Mars you go ahead and tell
Felix something telling something you
just swear I don't like things or what's
not necessarily swear but you just say a
bunch of things
yelling them to no one else is he is he
sitting for his computer when he does it
[Music]
every done that run you just just swear
for the reason I mean yeah I guess my
sin means though is that I write I think
of something yeah and it pisses me off
and I write I curse out so much go
mother's mind right I got it I got I got
a heavy mind what can I say yeah this is
that I do it in Swedish so you should be
happy oh my gosh okay what I don't like
so so Mary does like these review videos
you know on our channel like she gets
free stuff mm-hmm
and we never should ever really gets rid
of it it just kind of howls oh my god
and it's oh my god just like hoarding
like this is a real intervention this is
Becca I walk into the closet to get some
clothes and there's just like 800 pairs
of shoes that she'll never wears yeah oh
my god I go in today like the dining
room and our table is
[Laughter]
[Music]
we got a package of something and it
just keeps it keeps piling up yeah so I
feel like I have a system though oh
right please tell me but my bed is stuff
that I need to film and so I can't move
that until I film otherwise I lose it
you forgot to stay there next next our
beds like a dressing and nice just like
there's a mirror on the dresser but you
can't really you can like see the top of
your head maybe cuz there's so many
apparently a lot of videos need to be
made like five and eight a film right
now say oh my god so I get a lot of
stuff sent to me too but I throw it away
all the time and it gives me great great
Joey hey do you remember that bag hey
you had underneath the cabinet that you
said you were gonna donate to carry
charity even notice I can't keep track
of everything plan is really heavy so I
need your help that's why it stays there
whenever you're ready to help me oh nice
it's your fault
I really feel responsible I completely
understand while we're at it why why the
candles what is one need so many goddamn
cash you know when you come back home
and you're like oh this smells so bad it
does smell bad oh wait turn on a kennel
yeah it's gonna smell so nice and you
notice it right away so don't even
complain I'm doing it for us not just
for me plus if we're having dinner and
Kendall's going it's romantic and nice
you don't appreciate it but I do I feel
like my cousin with the candles is a
light one and I'll just leave it lit for
the entire day and I'm happy with that I
want it to be lit all day but ken will
be like you used a candle in one day's
your anyone in here we're in a different
room oh it's just as candle burning all
day I mean we the house could burn down
because it would be just like an effort
your question is why are you guys bother
so much by in about nice smells yeah I
enjoy my not nice smells in you know
like spending ten dollars in the candle
to be burned in one day I'm like wow
where did it go
yeah it ruins by a nice beautiful
authentic smell smell myself oh it's
good it aphrodisiacs yeah I'm sorry but
I'm sitting there like man that dog
pooped in the floor not stinks but all
the candles already burnt so I wish
you're saying I'm just saying we can you
know ration out the candle usage a
little bit it gets to a point where
eventually there's like diminishing
returns on how much smell is getting
into the air it sounds like we we
cleared the air a lot today let's love
my chest it sounds like I will stop
swearing out loud that's kinda it's not
fair they're like we went like two in a
row back to back we just kind of wound
her a rant there you know we should give
them one more I guess I've got I've got
one more ten sheds like a puppy dog all
this time he'll just shed his felt like
right now I'm looking around his office
there's just Ken hair like a carpet all
over our floors not that bad are you
talking about well it's all it gets in
the cool cuz I clean it up so I mean my
hair my hair it's black you know if it
falls out you're gonna see it but then
he will like shave his face it'll just
be all over the bathroom sink like I
I rinse it out you know like put some
water in my hand and swish it around and
it's a very hairy man hey I don't
understand you just gonna sit in the
shower you go in there to relax right
yeah I understand that like we have like
the regular I guess it's just like the
regular tub that has like a large area
in the back where you can like put a
whole lot of stuff and you can and you
can sit there and I just go and like
turn the water on and just sit down and
relax you know and then one and you have
like all your best creative ideas while
you're in the shower so you're gonna
stay in there for a while yeah so
everybody everybody clap yay for Mary
super Mary face game on you can check
out her channel she does like all the
cosplay makeup girly stuff that you know
whatever that we don't do on the similar
skin of a PewDiePie channel that's one
man she does creepy animations and
fashion hogs and so I can pay you look
summer have you every why should you get
any bit lately yes I happy but oh please
tell me yes I've been been watching
still watching parasites oh it's
fantastic so are you in good shape now
because you're running every time you
just my blood pumping I run so hard like
I write at least like 10 miles an
episode what do you use to watch in
what's your role good well I can tell
you a little bit about crunchyroll if
you're interested
no of course tell me all that
well I'm interested normally it's six
nine and five a month but if you sign up
now you get one month for free Oh
premium subscribers can also stream and
it shows in crispy toasty you would like
that Minji HD quality 1080p baby
you can pull beds you can watch anime
anytime anywhere on all the other
devices so you can get a 30 day free
trial by signing up at crunchyroll.com
it's nice papaya amazing amazing
oh my god it feels so good
no they're gone finally I don't have to
think about every word I say anymore
Hanna I mean we're probably in trouble
anyway but Mike was telling him that
stuff was like I don't want to look at
you while I tell you no no but she'll
she may get grumpy and be and it'll like
come back later and she bet man it will
come back later and like in in the right
moment you're like you said you'd be me
and you're like my way why can't you
just be mad right then and then get over
it oh yeah yeah anyway okay so we got we
got some kami ants
[Music]
Oh Harris went from Tommy hearty cane
and jacksepticeye ruined this episode
and can't stand him Wow Wow
the reason why okay so we I love Jack
he's great
you yeah he's a friend of ours but how
do I explain this so I always see hate
comments whenever I'm on his videos and
it breaks my heart every time cry
because I'm perfect right and people but
so whenever I see the opposite because
you don't really see the opposite you
just make everything about yourself is
like hmm someone were to mean common to
me but I saw this and I'm like thank you
Tom Tommy heart thank you very much
thank you
not about Jack it's about there was ton
of people who love Jack you pay in the
episode it was really funny one yeah oh
yeah it's this interesting hey can he go
I I saved a lot of us such a good guy uh
well here's a here's one from Josephine
Vesta Berg seems Swedish or maybe a copy
of your name but anyway it says I hope
can never will find analysis what pude
said in Swedish to him lol just to keep
them friend-zoned smiley face with
Hodgins what did you say to me in
Swedish just getting quiet engine yeah
yeah maybe say y'all so I can look at it
quite soon
stop it there you go
forever friendzone ken bing it unless
unless just a few bites Prague spoil
said hopefully she will cuz I don't
remember to look at her we got a lot of
a lot of memes from the meme episode and
a lot of them were of brandon fraiser
my favorite and i like that baseball
on that out of all things brandon
fraiser that's that's the mean now but
it does work really well brandon fraiser
for those of you don't know is the guy
from mummy and monkey bones or someone
pointed out those movies that you
watched as a kid yeah we got a picture
of brandon fraiser from woodsey TV and
it says when she says is it in yet and
then there's brandon fascias yeah he's
just like I just love that phase goes to
literally anything you know I like the
meat that this Alma Alma that says that
moment when pewter destroys a meme hey
you know you don't like no what do you
mean what do you you created it and
destroyed it all the same damn you are
God destroy your memes pewdiepie yeah
when you found out you missed the
McDonald's breakfast time
then that face is that random phrase
different like you just can't believe it
when you find out your partner is is as
into dudes no wait it's okay this is not
working out for me I think the one whose
guy's head caucus like IKEA Polti and
Taco Bell because I guess people
compared a lot I don't know sounds like
an American joke I don't get it now like
I also like the one that says ninja
ninja yeah yeah like in there what's
that movie called
oh my god wait why don't you talk about
their fault in our stars' the pole nurse
ours there we go yeah ninja ninja ninja
ninja this right Indian yeah this is it
what the was it still yeah or is it like
a different I don't know ken don't how
do you not know shut up
we also have one who send me dick bud
but he's gone for a nested I don't know
if he made that but if he did impress
him it's basically dick dick but but
instead it's a girl that has boobs
between her butt cheek
yeah she's beautiful okay don't even
show that maybe have to put sister
Corazon
thumbnail yeah yeah I like the one this
is like Mario fanfictions Internet I
give up the guys like that when the
throw in the mouse away yeah yeah
someone took my my too many teams mean
and they made it see that's great they
made they made it better keep spreading
the mean it's ten heaven to me just ever
have those little nubs I can't finish
come on man how come ya we we appreciate
you guys comments and it's funny to see
when you do [ __ ] like this keep it up
nobody nobody use mommy miss for
anything scream deep keep talking [ __ ]
if I can and Jack and everyone will be
happy that's just that's what it is no
one use your means yeah that's kind of
sad nobody loves me I think they did but
I chose these comments that's why don't
worry don't worry
okay you're bringing me down man you
just bring me down you can select your
own [ __ ] comments canned alright how
about that no I'm sorry how am I gonna
select comments on your video anyway
that's a good point that's a good point
well at least at least I didn't feel
like that means one bad ones for you
like Jack mmm
know that we can find any that's why you
know there's one on there that said
something about they like your accent
more than mine screw them yeah yeah yeah
Kylie McCaffrey I prefer a Felix accent
over Ken's well I prefer Felix over her
so burn we get Marg last one Mars
mandala Bayon - [ __ ] me what happened
it's a picture of someone posing in like
the V arms kind of to be honest Peter
price sucks I watched his videos horror
games and watches videos horror games
and rage games before and it was funny
but now he just plays non horror and
photoshopping so boring and not funny
how'd March how dare you yeah let me
tell you March I can't see your face but
I bet it's full of horror and needs a
lot of photoshopping
so maybe those things
oh yeah it's always kind of sad to me
how like no one ever wants you to change
onto YouTube it's like oh I'm tired of
playing these same games all the time
but then people are like no you have to
keep playing the exact same stuff oh
people are stuck in the pipe man
I don't have a nobody this you've played
all the horror games keep playing this
game ever right I tried to find a bunch
of horror games and it's so hard these
days to find a proper horror game I mean
that that that's that's a tapped
resource it is it's like it's it's over
unless there's a new one coming out I
won't i won't battle in there anymore
it's just a dark and horrible place
speaking of horror games that aren't
really horror games I guess have you
been playing blood-borne
nah haven't played it very much
what we're waiting for all my friends is
getting a Playstation and I'm waiting
for him ok well that's nice maybe you
can play with your other friend well
maybe my other friend has good internet
and I can't play with him and I'm gonna
move since a lot better I can but what
about what about blood-borne worry go
away it's ok let me let me explain this
so you guys who are listening understand
what I'm talking about so if someone
says they're they they they like the
game they you'll be like hey what's your
favorite game and they'd be like a eggs
it's Dark Souls it's it's two options
either they heard of the game and
they're like oh ID you will boss because
they know how awesome it is or second
option which is oh heas two hips
oh you don't know what blood Dark Souls
is well I'm cooler than you because you
don't know what that is
all right yeah the explanation hey you
lost me a little bit but I kinda I think
I can piece together of stuff that makes
sense in my head in every bite explain
it to our it doesn't make any sense I
was just trying to give an idea that's
that's how it is and and doctor this is
[ __ ] awesome blood-borne to me and is
even better I know you didn't think so
yeah but I think it's a lot well I
haven't got that into it like I've
gotten I mean I played it for a few
hours
I've got into the third boss which takes
is it me to me flat boss me clean boss
yeah old meat flap about Andy it's kinda
hard haven't beat it yet that boss okay
go ahead what I was just gonna say I
kind of like the combat how they have it
now like in Dark Souls and Demon's Souls
you can use your shield and you can just
kind of sit there yeah had enough
endurance yeah but now you're like no
you get you gotta you gotta move you got
it you got it
Dark Souls was bad you had the shield
you hold up your shield and then you
wait patiently and it's kind of boring
for the right move to attack a
blood-borne is more about you have to
play more offensively otherwise you're
dead
yeah which is awesome that's true and it
works
I actually someone set I summon someone
and then I was like yeah I'm too boss
for this I'm gonna kill myself and be in
myself and then I and I spent two hours
struggling and I regretted it for two
hours genius genius me um I don't know
also blood-borne is giving me nightmares
now well yes
I don't want to spoil you late but
there's a there's a thing in the game
that you can't see until later in the
game which is really creepy to me and
and then I found it I I just I got and
it got stuck in my brain and I had the
same nightmare and I was really bad I
wanted to cry did you wake up cursing
and nothing I did yes sitting by there
by the bed just straight up straight for
like I don't know a minute and then
what way you're sitting up straight what
are you thinking about the the me flat
monster yes every day I wish you a
beautiful but excited because it's
poisonous the thing so I can't do
anything about it alright so we
collected some of the best questions
that you left us only the finest of the
finest
and we're here to help you solve your
problem
[Music]
so you kissing their ass right now can
don't do that mwah if they're if that's
my finger I guess I can't look like a
butthole just a little butthole talk
today I let the scrunchie but sounds
weird stop please
okay let's focus we need to help people
here they're desperate right right
they're desperate they're waiting people
are in need and they've come to the
right place yes we are they're so fresh
that I haven't even taken any notes
whatsoever this time because people are
complaining that I read too much I'm
sorry
I'm trying to prepare and give you a
thoughtful answer sorry that's too bad
for you so you know you get a half good
answer anyway first question is from
Lena and she says hi boots and Ken two
of my closest friends developed romantic
feelings for one another
ooh sounds juicy I like this and as a
result I feel like the third wheel Oh
Oh Elena's in trouble of course I'm in
no position to rain on their happiness I
mean why not but can you give me advice
on how to better deal with the situation
especially the male counterpart seem to
vastly prefer my other friend the one he
has feelings for okay and since we have
been a trio of sorts for a long time
it's kind of hurtful to me how things
have changed compared to how they used
to be and lost how do I deal with a
situation mm-hmm and I'm lost too
Alina you're you're done it's not you've
done it it sounds like making friends
for a while and it's weird how this
would happen all of a sudden well it
says the closest for yes so I mean it's
kind of crazy if they were they were all
friends they're already in the frit they
broke out of the friendzone roof the
Franks how did they do it ask them well
you have I can't believe it I don't know
if I believe the story so what's a
possible I mean I please don't waste her
time with these made-up questions right
please please if this is true tell us
how to happen so we can tell the world
you're you are you're the sensei the
master no not her friends Oh ass true
yeah
but yeah this kind of weird how that
would happen all the sudden but they
would just be like hey we're into each
other name we've been friends for a long
time but now we're into each other it
sounds like if they make if they broke
out of that there's no way there you
know and Lina has a chance to sneak in
unless at Lina just what they did and
breaks out of the friendzone - and they
can just have a triangle
I love how about the love the love
friendzone breaking out of triangle yep
it can be naughty it can be done with
naughty relationships I don't see no I
was talking like any good advice to give
cos a pretty selfish question really
isn't my best friends they like each
other but now I don't feel special
anymore well why can't you be friends of
them still they're just gonna be making
out and stuff you are a third will at
this point who knows maybe they planned
this from the start
that's kind of harsh yeah oh I heard for
Alina um you know she's got to get over
if I really had to give an advice I
would say be upfront about it
tell them how you feel tell them that
you feel left out and if they don't
agree then [ __ ] them there you go you're
welcome Alina can do you have another
question yeah I got one from Celso I
think his name though he's sad it's
jealous though there's no H miss kill so
I don't know yeah cels oh yeah okay hi
guys my name is chelsa I'm 15 and I have
a situation
oh damn I'm in the tenth grade of school
so last year I changed of wait yeah last
year I changed of class what and I met a
lot of people the changes I got really
close to this girl called Kwajalein Lana
Lana and I found out that she really
likes me but the problem is that I felt
in love with a those marks with a girl
with a girl called Joanna oh my grade
but there hasn't been a period yet
and I kinda still like her but she never
wanted something with me and now we're
very distant from each other that's fine
okay so the situation here is I like
both but the problem is that one is
distance of me and don't want anything
with me and the other girl is very
closed with me and she likes me should I
choose
brofist and I'll try to stay toasty PS
forgot about my English oh wait sorry
about my English Missy poor guy I don't
know but I appreciate that sorry can you
summarize there's two kiwanis one chest
so there's two quanah's one let me a guy
actually got to read over again he got
really close to one you wanna but the
problem is he was in love with another
one two years ago that doesn't want
anything to do with him and now he's
asking this should he choose
well doesn't really seem like you have
much of a choice
so you should probably go with the one
you have a chance then though you may be
like in love with the guy I guess it's
the you should chase love love the one
that you're the one that got away but
she doesn't know anything to do with him
I guess that's where he's gonna give it
if she doesn't want anything to do with
him and I mean that's why I go and go
without this one you have to wanna in
the world is going to tell you welcome I
never met anyone called Quanah or
Johanna for that matter so it's really
weird but tell so yeah go for the other
corner and sup which one are you asked
don't know it's just get a whole day
whatever wanna you can get get is what
you want to do get a phone book
doesn't really exist anymore just look
up wanna and then you got a good
selection there just go from there you
have probably about as much chance with
those who want us as you do that's the
one that you fell in love with as they
used to say there's plenty of wanting
the sea yes
[Music]
there's always bigger quantity is that I
always believe me your father's out to
get okay do you have another question I
do and this one is from an anonymous no
yeah no no no you can't be anonymous you
can't just ask us question tonight we
have we have to know who you are so we
can ridicule you and your name no it's
okay because that means that means you
know we want honest questions and that
means they're gonna be more on and on
this now that they're anonymous
that right app is what have you done to
me yeah ruined actually entertained
impressed with this my life for the next
few days or weeks I recently started
watching great teacher onizuka yes yes
the anime I was telling about see it
might see I am the animate senpai I just
said all Sofia so cool it's okay thank
you thank you and I shall be blessed
with some great honeymoon oh but I'm
funny difficult to start watching it and
unfortunately it has infinite amount of
episodes yeah it's a really long series
I think it's really old once I finished
with GTO what should i watch next
and Ken this doesn't mean that if you
have a good suggestion
you can't answer either in fact I want
WOD answer yeah I don't need your
permission to answer anonymous well we
get get out of here
you don't run this play you don't run
this show how do you think you are
Oh anonymous right lucky I don't know I
hate and not a miss efficient what
happened I haven't got that not I got
that anonymous ass yeah but to go say
whatever they want to say because
they're not a mess it's true that was a
little sassy I did detective love a
disaster luckily you know we can hook
you up with the crunchyroll
crunchyroll.com sized pewdiepie and if
you sign up get 30 day free trial of any
moons and ice I wanted to suggest
mushishi Lucy she sounds like it's like
a sushi roll would you like some more
sushi yes um if it was the sushi roll it
would have been delicious will be gonna
be crunchy
it's about a medicine man I think and he
goes around and then there's usually
like a problem with the spirit and he
has to find out the problem and then he
clears it out hmm it's similar to my
favorite one of my favorite enemies
which is Mononoke not the [ __ ]
princess mononoke stupid everyone loves
that anime and it pisses me off every
time because I like more Nanaki more
yeah yeah and it's the same concept it's
about a medicine man who clears people
spirit and he's written it's a horror
horror genre okay
that's pretty cool that lesson how would
they have it on pressure oh there you go
yay you watch it and getting get
nightmares welcome yeah welcome
hard ones mmm so we got one more
question from Abby Abby here says hi
Canon Felix hi Abby
hey glad Ulysses your name yeah so hey
it's AIT's a hobby hobby see how it me
try to imagine what Abby's voice would
be like mmm here we go hi cannon Felix
so proms prom season is coming up dot
dot dot and I really want to ask my
friend if he'll go with me not really as
a date just as a friend
well previously I don't want to make him
feel obligated to pay for dinner flowers
eccentric Wow Wow Abby Wow for context
he's a junior and I'm a senior I've only
known him since last summer but we've
gotten pretty close and I want to have a
problem asking if he had go with me
except he's really shy and kind of
awkward it might not be comfortable with
the prom scene my friends NarL and my
friends are all encouraging me I need an
idea on how to make it special and not
over-the-top so I figured of course I
had to find a half that I have to ask
those two guys on the internet for
advice thanks guys
sideways smiley face
oh are you going to bomb oh and taking a
junior no less mmm scandalous I have a
lot of thoughts about this but I don't
think I understand the dynamic really
especially from what you just said a
junior prom she wants to bring in you to
prom but he's awkward and shot so we
don't have problems so she's scared to
ask the shy guy because she's shy is
that is that what I'm getting here no
she's gonna make us why did she want to
take him okay here's what I get from
this guy he's younger than her which is
kind of unusual it's not bad thing but
it's it's there he's shy and kind of
awkward which kind of adds another layer
to that and you want to bring him to a
place where it will just be kind of
probably awkward and weird that's what I
get out of this well it's your prom it's
special you gotta be gotta bring
somebody and I I didn't go to my problem
did I get a mom yeah I did okay that's
it yeah I went but I get ate some food
lift
oh but anyway it sounds fun yeah it's
not about us it's about hobby hobby well
I'll let you take this one cause I don't
understand proms
yeah oh I know about problems is like
every teen movie ever then there's never
like that prey you just promise you go
into a room and if it like Napoleon
Dynamite promise sit around tables mmm
every promise different I guess it could
be like a dance or something you want it
to be but usually it's just like hey
we're done kind of thing bring a date
get some pictures maybe dress vanity to
go to my prom okay my bad
yeah I need at least a prawn it was it
was awful East the problems not like the
high school dance where it's just a
bunch of like tweens grinded on each
other while adults have to watch
awkwardly any was amazing so she wants
advice on how to make it special to ask
him to go yeah I mean they haven't had
their he's shy and awkward if you like
made something like special effort he'd
probably be like Sean awkward about it I
heard
yeah they just ruin the whole thing so
you should probably just ask him if he
wants to go yeah if it's if it's your
did she say that we're a close friend
maybe it was a friend it shouldn't be
that hard if you're already friends yeah
it's not a date because she doesn't want
to feel obligated for stuff let me just
the prom that's not really a date anyway
I guess yes for some people but they
usually give you food and stuff you
don't play breathing except your tuxedo
so if you don't have to pay for anything
it's not a date yes it's kinda it's kind
of a weird question
it's got a lot of that a lot of angles I
mean don't make a big spectacle out of
it just add maybe write a note yeah with
that Abby don't be shy and awkward about
this yes you can have two people being
shy awkward that is thanks to penises
singing each other that's just that just
causes like that sounded retention and
sexual attention and you're only in high
school when you don't need that in your
life don't rub two pieces together or
you'll make babies you're well you're
welcome Abby yeah nailed it all right so
that was the broken podcast great
episode leaving your comments at hashtag
broken podcast subscribe to us on iTunes
keep rating it up because we need to
beat all the other youtubers and boat
down if you can other people that'd be
great yeah definitely and we appreciate
that you watch and we need a good outro
cuz I'm roll of the jacksepticeye outro
[Laughter]
if you enjoyed this video once dead like
butter like a boss and in Boucher Holly
rattled all around and we can't just
steal his outro we do yeah but he
basically covers everything good in 1
outro what else can you do yeah alright
stay toasty my broski's
like a paw
ah